Guten Tag, mein Name ist Senor Aydin. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistant
und würde gerne mitten das Ausnahmigespräch führen. Sind Sie damit ein Verständnis?
Ja, natürlich. Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder etwas fragen möchten, geben Sie mir eine
Becher. Ja, ich sage jetzt schon mal, es geht mir ein bisschen schnell. Sprechen Sie bitte
ein bisschen langsamer. Jetzt frage ich ganz kurz zur Ihrer Person.
Nachher höre ich Ihren Beschwerden so. Wie heißen Sie denn? Ich heiße Marie Luise
Reinhheimer. Marie Luise ist ein Doppelname. Okay, bitte könntest du Sie Ihren vor und nach
Namen langsam bestabilen. Ja, M-A-R-I-E. Okay. Und dann Bindestrich und dann Luise, L-U-I-S-E.
Okay, und Luise ist der Vorname und der Familie namn ist Reinhheimer mit S-E-I-N.
Reinhheimer. Okay, Frau Reinhheimer. Wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 48 Jahre alt. 58. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
19.10.73. 19.10.73. Okay. Wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin 1,78 m.
Und wie schwer sind Sie? 83 kg. Okay, gut, Frau Reinhheimer. Was für Beschwerden haben Sie? Was kann ich zum Sieben?
Ich habe solche unglaublichen krampfartigen Oberbauchschmerzen. Und zwar eigentlich mehr auf der rechten Seite und das strahlt bis in die rechte Schulter hoch und auch in den Rücken rein.
Auch Rücken. Okay. Dann rechten Rücken oder beiden? Ja, auf der rechten Seite so. Okay. Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Dass ich solche Schmerzen habe, das habe ich seit gestern Abend. Seit gestern Abend. Da hat es plötzlich angefangen. Nach dem Abendessen hat es plötzlich angefangen.
Haben Sie für dich schon in dir Beschwerden? Ja, ich habe in letzter Zeit schon so fettiges Essen nicht gut vertragen.
Also wenn ich Kuchen mit Sahne gegessen habe, da habe ich schon gemerkt, war es mal nicht so gut. Aber gestern Abend habe ich eben Bratkartoffeln gegessen.
Und jetzt habe ich diese unglaublichen Schmerzen, das ist ganz unangenehm.
Okay. Das heißt, haben die Schmerzen nach dem Essen aufgetreten? Die sind genau nach dem Essen, hat es angefangen.
Okay. Wie stark sind die Schmerzen? Auf einer Schmerzskalation 1 bis 10. Wobei 1 sehr leichte und 10 sehr starken Schmerzen entspielen.
Also da würde ich sagen, wenn das so richtig losgeht, dann sind die bestimmt bei 8. 8.
Okay. Haben Sie etwas gegen Schmerzen eingenommen? Schmerzen mit der Oder etwas anderes? Nein, ich habe jetzt noch nichts eingenommen, weil es ja so plötzlich gekommen ist.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, ich komme lieber hier gleich zu Ihnen. Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Veränderungen gemacht, zum Beispiel Gadzut oder andere?
Ja, mein Mann hat gesagt, meine Augen würden so gelb aussehen. Das hatte ich irgendwie vor 2 Tagen mir gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, du spinnst, du hast dich verguckt, das falsche Licht oder so.
Mir ist halt total schlecht und ich konnte jetzt heute noch nichts wieder essen.
Und ich habe tatsächlich auch ein bisschen Temperatur.
Temperatur. Haben Sie das über die Temperatur gemessen? Ja, ich bin so um 38 Grad mit der Temperatur.
38 Grad. Und ich habe mich tatsächlich auch seit gestern Abend schon 3 Mal übergeben.
Und da ist das ganze Essen wieder ausgekommen. Und das sah so aus, als ob da auch so ein bisschen Blut wird dabei.
Blut im Ebra.
Haben Sie noch andere Becher?
Oder nach Schweiß haben Sie oder Schüttelfrust?
Nein, das ist mir eigentlich nicht so schlimm, ist das Fieber ja nicht.
Ich fühle mich nur total schlecht und übeln und geben diese Schmerzen.
Frau Reinhame, sind Ihre Schmerzen mit dem Atmen verbunden, einatmen oder bei einem aussatzen?
Ich bin mir jetzt noch nicht so aufgefallen, ich muss sich mal ausprobieren.
Ich glaube, so hat mit dem Atmen nichts zu tun.
Okay. Haben Sie noch andere Becher?
Ja, was mir aufgefallen ist, wenn ich auf die Toilette gebe, am Wasser lassen, dass der Urin irgendwie dunkler aussieht als sonst.
Dunkler. Wann haben Sie das bemerkt?
Ja, seit wenigen Tagen habe ich, ich habe mir dabei nichts gedacht, das habe ich vielleicht anders gegessen oder so.
Aber jetzt ist mir das in dem Zusammenhang, ist das schon auffällig.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder haben Sie etwas Veränderungen beim Stuhl bemerkt?
Nee, du hast mir nichts aufgefallen.
Okay. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt, ab oder zu genommen?
Nein.
Nein, okay. Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise eigentlich schon, aber jetzt natürlich, heute Nacht habe ich nicht gut geschlafen.
Okay. Frau Reinhheimer, haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen, um denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel so Krankheit, Herzkrankheit.
Nein, ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, dann nehme ich aber B-Lock-Sock dagegen ein.
Und was ich tatsächlich habe, das ist ein grüner Starr.
Und zwar beiden Auren.
Okay. Seit wann haben Sie Arterellehipertoni?
Den Blutdruck habe ich schon seit sechs, sieben Jahren.
Sieben?
Okay. Kennen Sie die Dosis vom Belock-Sock?
Ja, das ist Belock-Sock 95 Sekunde.
Eine nehme ich da morgens.
Okay. Und Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie Grün-Echter haben.
Und haben Sie noch andere Krankheiten?
Ja, das sind eigentlich die entscheidenden Sachen.
Ich hatte einen Arbeitsunfall, da hatte ich mir das Handgelenk gebrochen.
Das ist mit Platten und Trauben versorgt worden. Das ist nicht so richtig gut verheilt.
Da habe ich manchmal noch Beschwerden.
Aber sonst ist alles gut.
Nehmen Sie etwas dagegen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Muss arbeiten, das kann ich mir nicht erlauben.
Was ich noch regelmäßig machen muss, ich muss halt die Augen regelmäßig tropfen.
Augen tropfen.
Kennen Sie deinen Namen von Tropfen?
Ja, das heißt Timonhexal.
Dann muss ich abends und morgens in beide Augen tropfen.
Gibt es noch andere Krankheiten?
Nein, das ist eigentlich alles.
Okay. Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Als Kind habe ich eine Windermopie gehabt.
Und dann natürlich diese Hand-Opie, von der ich erzählt habe.
Und Handgelenk-Opie hatte Sie.
Was haben Sie diese Operation?
Solange her, das ist so zwölf Jahre.
Warum haben Sie eine Handgelenk-Opie?
Als Kind war ich sieben oder acht Jahre alt.
Sie wissen nicht, wann das war.
Weißt du, dass ich klein war.
Gibt es noch andere Operation?
Nein.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Krankenhaus gewesen?
Wir haben Landwirtschaft, da kann man sich nicht viel erlauben.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie Belöcksung und Augen tropfen.
Und manchmal Schmerzmittel.
Ich nehme meine Aspirin, wenn es zu doll wird.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Allergie gegen Medikamente oder Levels mit?
Ja, und zwar ziemlich viele.
Ich habe einmal eine Jodallergie.
Ich habe bei meinem Beruf Heuchenupfen.
Ich habe eine Allergie gegen Birkenpollen und Haselmüsse.
Wie ist Ihre Allergie gegen Birkenpollen und Haselmüsse?
Haben Sie noch eine Allergie gegen Birkenpollen oder Haselmüsse?
Nein, das ganze Programm reicht mir nicht.
Es sind ja noch viele Allergie, die ich habe.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Früher haben Sie geraucht, oder?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich habe nur 3 Gläser.
Sie trinken 2 oder 3 Gläser am Abend?
2 oder 3.
Nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage für Reinhheimer.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein, das ist nicht wahr.
Sehr gut.
Gibt es in der Familie ein krönliches Krankheit?
Ja, mein Vater ist an einem Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Meine Mutter ist in der Pflegeeinrichtung.
Sie hat ein Alzheimer.
Das ist auch sehr anstrengend.
Er hat eine Lebersterose.
Lebersterose?
Okay.
Im Märchen ist der Vater gestorben?
Er war Anfang 70.
Okay.
Hat Mutter auch andere Krankheiten?
Nein, das ist auch eine Demenz.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe 2 Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Leben Sie mit Ihrem Mann?
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Landwirtin.
Landwirtschaftin?
Wir haben einen Landwirtschaftlichen Betrieb.
Okay, verstanden.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, da hat man immer Stress.
Klar, weil die Arbeit nie aufhört,
weil wir die Wochenende haben,
weil wir nicht in Urlaub fahren können
und weil nicht genug Geld reinkommt.
Das ist schon oft Probleme in der Landwirtschaft.
Okay, verstanden.
Ist Ihre Monatsverlütung regelmäßig?
Ich habe schon lange keine Periode mehr.
Ich bin sehr früh in die Wechseljahre gekommen.
Ich hatte jetzt mit 45 die letzte Periode.
Ich habe alles gefragt, was ich brauche.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinstoffieren?
Ich will wissen, wo das jetzt herkommt
und was man dagegen tun kann.
Zuerst muss ich einige Umteile suchen.
Ich möchte ein paar Umteile suchen.
Ich möchte gar nichts cavellen.
Dann können wir uns darüber sprechen.
Ja, da gibt es noch Fragen von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Von mir aus war das eigentlich auch komplett.
Mögen Sie gleich ins Arztgespräch einsteigen oder wollen Sie erst noch ein bisschen gucken?
Ich habe ganz kurze Zeit für Vorbereitung.
Ja, ok. Da schicke ich mir nochmal Tee ein.
Ich möchte eine Frage stellen.
Sie haben vor Dogra gesagt.
Vorhin ja.
Das heißt reiche Krankheiten, wir nennen in der Türkei so etwas.
Reichen Krankheiten.
Das war tatsächlich hier in früheren Zeiten auch die Krankheit der reichen Leute.
Die waren erstens fett und die haben viel Fleisch gegessen.
Deswegen haben die eben diese Harnsäureansammlung und diese Ansammlung von Purinen gehabt in der Nahrung.
Und das hat bei den Leuten eben die Gicht ausgelöst.
Genau. Es ist sicherlich keine Krankheit, die man in Hungergebieten in Afrika findet.
Ich glaube zumindest nicht.
Reichen Krankheiten ist wahrscheinlich gut.
Reichen Krankheiten.
Ich habe das doch richtig verstanden.
Das ist eine Krankheit der reichen Leute.
Gicht, Deutsche und Gut in der Türkei umgangssprachische Reichkrankheit.
Eine Krankheit der reichen Leute.
Weil die zu viel gegessen haben.
Herr Gündes meint, dass diese Krankheit Name ist Gicht.
Gut, der andere Name Podorba.
Nein, Podorba heißt nur der Anfall, der sich auf das großzehnte Grundgelenk bezieht.
Gicht ist die Krankheit, die man allgemein hat.
Die Neigung zu diesem Gicht anfällt und es manifestiert sich besonders gerne in diesem großzehnten Grundgelenk.
Und diese Attacke speziell nennen wir Podorba.
Ja, aber Krankheit heißt Giedisch.
Gicht heißt die Ja.
Gicht.
Was heißt das?
Ich habe auch noch ein Lateinisch Namen.
Ja, genau.
Das habe ich neu erinnert.
Also, gut, Artritis, großartritis heißt Podorba.
Gut, mal eben schnell.
Artritis, Artritis, Urica.
Artritis, Urica, genau, ja, ja, ja, genau.
Kann man mit Gicht, Artritis, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, das stimmt, Artritis, Urica, so heißt es.
Genau, die Kristalle, die Kristalle der Hand, die Sätze, sich in den Gelenken ab.
Deutsche Maul, die, da steht, Artritis, Urica, genau, ja, sehr gut.
Vielen Dank für die Tipp.
Können wir?
Ja, ich bin bereit, ich kann anfangen.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarsten, haben Sie kurze Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Eine neue Patientin.
Frau Marie-Louise Reinhheimer ist 58-jährige Patientin.
58?
58, ja, ich habe 48.
40, ja.
48, aber sie ist in deinem Wegster.
Ja, richtig.
Sie ist in, in, in dem Wegsterjahr.
Ja, hat sie gesagt, genau.
Okay, okay.
Frau Marie-Louise Reinhheimer ist 48-jährige Patientin,
die sich bei uns seit gestern bestehenden Schmerzen im rechten Oberbau
mit Ausstrahlung direkt der Schulter und Rücken vorgestellt hat.
Die Patienten beschreiben die Schmerzen krampfartig und bewertet auf eine Schmerzskala,
von der es bis 10, bei 8.
Und laut der Patientin sind die Schmerzen nach der Petrikes Essen aufgetreten
und die Schmerzen haben plus die Begumme.
Desweiter sind der Patienten folgende Begleitungen,
sind aufgefeilt, ichterus, Fibar 38°, 3-maliges Emesis
und Dunkelbrinn seit einigen Tagen.
Und am Vorerkrankungen gab die Patienten
von der Arteriella-Hypertonie von Sibbeln,
behandelt mit 90 mg,
behandelt mit 90 mg, Morgan Smith-Albens,
Glowcom, behandelt mit Algenprobsen,
Sweimar-Technik und
Handgelegschmerzen,
infolge eines Arbeitsunfall
und die Patienten nimmt manchmal
Schmerzmittel, Arteriella-Silesil,
und bei der Patientin eine Dündarm-Op
in der Kindheit begleitet,
die Arteriella-Silesil ist nicht klar.
Die Patienten hat allergiegegenjot, Birkenpolen
und Hazelnuss, die sich mit
Rhenokonjuktivitis und Prioritis
und auch bei der Patientin
Pencilin und Tetrasin allerginn bekannt,
die Patienten ist nicht raucherin,
aber trink 2-3 Gläserwein am Abend
und drücken Konsum auch, wurden verneint.
In der Familienanmese
fanden sich Arteriella-Hypertol,
in der Familienanmese fanden sich
Demenz bei der Mutla
und Vater ist im Alter von 70
gestorben und Bruder leidet
leber Syrose. Die Patienten ist verheiratet,
hat 2 Kinder, die gesund sind
und sie ist Land mit Formberuf
und mescht die Arbeit als Stress.
Und die Patienten ist schon in den Wechseljahren.
Genau.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Kolangitis.
Was haben Sie als Differenzialdiagnose?
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen
Colestitis und Pancreatitis
und Pyronephritis in Betracht.
Was noch?
Repetitis, kann sein.
Basalepnomenie, vielleicht, kann sein.
Hier war noch etwas anderes genannt.
Bei der Kolangitis, was werden da die Ursache?
Kolangiolecitholitis
und Colenity.
Was haben Sie von Unterzuhung?
Bayer und Terzuhung,
mit der Syrosytheraikparameitan
messen und dann Körperliere und Terzuhung dünchführen.
Wo achten Sie da besonders?
Besonders auf Druckschmerz,
auf rechten Oberbau.
Was machen Sie operativ?
Operativ würde ich ablösen,
sondern durchführen.
Und Röntgen-Torax würde ich auch verändern.
Noch etwas?
Was wollen Sie im Labor?
Labor, kleines Blutmilch und Insulinkparameter
und Leberparameter
und Nierenparameter, Kreativ-Harnsöhe.
Was ist Leber, was interessiert Sie denn?
Gamagultamiltransferase,
ASD, ALT
und
Bilirubin.
Ja, Bilirubin,
ja, Bilirubin,
ja, Bilirubin, ja, Bilirubin,
ja, Bilirubin.
Ich habe eigentlich fast keine Ergänzung, hat jemand von den Kollegen noch fast zu ergänzen dazu?
Also eine Sache ist mir noch aufgefallen, B-Lock 95 gibt es nur, B-Lock 90 gibt es glaube ich gar nicht.
Und sie hat gesagt 1.0.0 nimmt sie und 1.0.1 macht sie bei den Augenpropfen.
Sie ist nur ein B-Lock-Zock.
B-Lock-Zock ist auch zweimal täglich, oder?
Einmal, einmal. Die haben aber bei den ersten 2-mal gesagt.
Das war das Einzige, was mir darauf gefallen ist.
Und also tatsächlich sollte das ein Stein sein.
Also wobei sie waren ja wirklich direkt daran mit der Kulavitis und dann haben sie ja als Differenzialdiagnose gesagt.
Die Untersuchungen werden ja genau in die Richtung gegangen.
Das ist also perfekt.
Und ja, ich bin jetzt in den Fragen zu diesem Fall, bin ich auf eine Sache eigentlich nur gestoßen.
Es gibt so eine 4F- bzw. 6F-Regelung für geilen Krankheiten. Kennen Sie das?
Ja, ja, ich wusste. Vielleicht kann ich es zählen.
Wir können mal gucken, was wir so hinfügen.
Frauen?
Ja, Female, genau.
Ja, Female, Fruchtbar.
Was?
Fruchtbar.
Fruchtbar?
Fruchtbar, schön. Okay, ich schuldige.
Übergewicht.
Ja, fertig.
Ja.
Und noch etwas?
Fair.
Ja, Fair.
Und dann habe ich tatsächlich noch neu gelernt, jetzt über 40, 40 und familiäre Disposition.
Ich kannte tatsächlich immer nur 4F, jetzt gibt es 6F.
Also über 40 und familiäre Disposition.
Es klappt alles nur mit Englisch.
Female, Fertile, Fair, 14 und Family.
Alles klar.
Gut.
Sprachlich, würde ich sagen, war das eine sehr perfekte Anamnese und auch eine sehr perfekte Darstellung.
Wann machen Sie Prüfung?
Am 6.20. zum Februar.
Das ist dann noch ein bisschen heilig.
Aber Sie könnten morgen zur Prüfung gehen, wäre echt kein Ding.
Am Anfang habe ich gedacht, oh, wir reden nur noch nicht schnell.
Aber dann habe ich gemerkt, dass Sie wirklich sehr, sehr gut formulieren.
Und.
Danke schön.
Nee, das ist sehr gut gelaufen, würde ich sagen.
Können Sie entspannt entgegen gucken?
Danke, aber es fällt mir schwer, gleichzeitig zu notizieren.
Das falsch geschrieben.
Ja, das denke ich mir, weil man sich einfach in der freien Sprache viel mehr konzentrieren muss.
Auf das, was man hört und so ein Patient redet ja auch weiter, während man versucht, was zu schreiben.
Ich meine klar, Sie machen, Sie gehen ja sehr strukturiert immer vor nach den Fragen.
Aber die Leute reden ja dazwischen und bringen ja die Sachen nicht immer in dem Zusammenhang, wo sie fragen.
Die Frau hat ja jetzt auch irgendwelche Symptome vorher schon geschildert, bevor sie überhaupt danach gefragt haben.
Und das ist immer das Problem, dass man das sensortieren muss, dass man es richtig aufschreibt.
Und auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch, dass man nachher nicht noch mal fragt.
Nach dem Motto habe ich mir noch gerade schon gesagt.
Aber ich finde, es ist wirklich sehr, sehr gut gelaufen.
Und Sie können glaube ich sehr zufrieden sein.
Bitte Ihnen, guten Erfolg bei der Prüfung.